today the mat well show Shocker of
shockers it appears the bite
Administration is lying about the
Brittany Greiner trade evidence suggests
they did indeed choose her over other
Americans trapped in Russia like former
Marine Paul Whalen we'll talk about that
also Elon Musk releases more documents
revealing the truth about how Twitter
was run behind the scenes and with this
latest release yet another right-wing
quote conspiracy theory has been
confirmed plus the Biden
administration's most notorious luggage
Thief has added again and Jennifer
Lawrence applauds herself for being the
first woman ever to star in an action
film apparently Jennifer Lawrence has
never seen any movies aside from the
ones that she's been in all of that and
more today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
you know I know as well as anybody that
it can be really hard to maintain a
healthy lifestyle when you've got a busy
schedule and you're always looking for
excuses and life can provide those
excuses but you got to get rid of them
and that's why I'm a huge fan of balance
of nature balance of nature fruits and
veggies are the best way to make sure
you're getting essential nutritional
ingredients every single day their
products are 100 Whole Food balance of
nature uses a cold vacuum process that
preserves the natural phytonutrients and
whole fruits and vegetables and
encapsulates them for easy consumption
bounce of nature sent a bunch of their
products down to the studio for my team
to try and we all love them so when
you're disciplined enough to take care
of your health you reap all the kinds of
uh benefits that are available more
energy less fatigue better focused
consuming the right balance of fruits
and vegetables every day is an important
First Step so go to balanceofnature.com
use promo code Walsh for 25 off your
first order as a preferred customer plus
a free fiber and spice that's a
balanceofnature.com promo code Welsh for
25 off your first preferred order
when we first heard the news that WNBA
player Brittany Greiner was being
released from detainment in Russia in
exchange for the world's most notorious
arms dealer a man our own government has
nicknamed The Merchant of death some of
us were immediately suspicious about the
reasoning behind this decision this was
especially the case given the fact that
other Americans like former Marine Paul
Whalen school teacher Mark Fogle were
left to languish in Russian labor camps
while the basketball player was brought
home as we talked about yesterday the
bite Administration claims that they
didn't choose to leave Weyland out of it
as far as Fogle goes they're not even
acknowledging him his existence at all
really they say that Russia never gave
them any option it was either trade for
Griner or for No One
of course if that was the case given
what they're being asked to give up they
should have just chosen no one in that
case I mean Joe Biden literally hours
before finalizing this deal and not a
lot of people noticed this yesterday but
hours before finalizing this deal he was
speaking at a vigil to honor victims of
gun violence
and then proceeded to orchestrate the
release of the world's most notorious
gun Runner so if they really took gun
violence seriously they wouldn't be so
willing to release a man like that back
into the wild especially why while they
also tell us
that Putin is a crazed dictator bent on
global destruction and that the war in
Ukraine is just the first step in
Russia's attempted takeover of the world
I mean I've always been quite skeptical
of that claim but if it's true you
probably don't want to give him back his
Merchant of Death at a time such as this
and perhaps you know uh what we're
learning here shocker Shockers is that
the Biden Administration when it comes
to the topics of Russia or gun violence
or
anything else doesn't take its own hype
seriously but at any rate most of the
analysis even the critical analysis of
the grinder swap has assumed
that it's true that they could only
bring home Griner or no one
if indeed it is true the the trade is
still scandalously stupid but it becomes
a scandal of an entirely different level
if it isn't true if in fact they chose
Greiner over other Americans who had
been by the way suffering in captivity
for far longer than she had been
personally I assumed that was the case
from the beginning I assume it because I
reflexively disbelieve everything this
Administration says
um also because a grinder or no one
offer from Russia makes it easier on the
White House
okay what Russia would actually be doing
the White House a favor by saying we'll
give you her or we'll give you nobody
because it just makes it a simpler
choice
but Russia is not interested in making
things easier it it's it puts Biden in a
more precarious and politically
difficult situation to make him choose
which American he wants
and so it just makes logical sense that
Russia would prefer to put him in that
situation
especially because they likely knew that
he would humiliate himself and his
country by extension by choosing the
lesbian basketball player over the
Marine
and by the way I just saw we can't play
the clip because it's in Russian you
wouldn't understand it but uh I saw a
clip circulating of of Russian media
last night and a woman on Russian media
talking about this case and doing
exactly this mocking Biden for choosing
you know she says that that that Biden
was offered a choice between Weyland or
Griner chose Greiner and as the woman on
Russia TV points out
you know they made that choice because
you know Waylon goes to the back of the
line because he's a white male and
heterosexual
so they're mocking him they're mocking
Biden for this
of course is what this is what the
Russians wanted they wanted the
opportunity to mock Biden for making
this choice that they knew he would make
and this seemed clear to many of us from
the start and but evidence is now
emerging
uh which strongly suggests that our
instincts were correct the journalist
named Jordan Satchel
um is following the trail he reports on
his substack he says for several months
the bite administration had been
publicly indicating their intent to try
to secure the release of both Griner and
Whalen in exchange for Mr bout before
announcing Thursday that they had
secured Griner in a one-for-one exchange
did the mighty Administration choose
Griner over Weyland although Biden
officials and the president himself have
denied that that was the case several
pieces of evidence seemed to indicate
that Greiner was indeed prioritized over
Weyland and that Moscow allowed the by
Administration to choose either
individual for the one-to-one swap the
corporate media citing senior vitamin
officials have uh delivered clues about
the prisoner swap option NBC News a
known regurgitator of State propaganda
stealth edited its story about the
decision to choose Brittany Greiner over
Paul Whalen
for reasons unknown NBC News citing a
senior U.S official changed its entire
narrative about the prisoner Exchange
the key paragraph in question for NBC's
story first read before being stealth
edited is what it read originally
quote a senior U.S official told NBC
news that the U.S government had sought
to have both Griner and Whalen released
as part of a swap with the Kremlin which
wanted the return of Victor bout a
Russian arms dealer was served 11 years
of a 25-year census U.S but the official
said Russia has treated Weyland
differently because he is an accused spy
and the Kremlin gave the White House the
choice of either Griner or Whalen or no
one
so it wasn't Greiner or no one but
Griner or Whalen or no one
that was NBC news report originally
then they edited it and this is what the
current version says but the official
said Russia has treated Weyland
differently because he's an accused spy
that the Kremlin ultimately gave the
White House the choice of either Griner
or no one after different options were
proposed
huh
after different options were proposed
wonder what those other options were
so we know they're rolling at full speed
with the cover-up when they start
rewriting paragraphs of news reports
after the reports have already been
published
but there's more going back to uh this
report it says the NBC report also cites
weyland's Russian lawyer quote Waylon's
Russian lawyer Vladimir zoren binkov
will say also said that the deal was in
exchange of one to one and that choosing
grinder 32 appeared more Humane quote
unquote because she's a woman and an
Olympic champion while Waylon was in the
military and it's easier for him to be
in custody zren pincov has uh previously
said that Russia offered a one-to-one
swap for Whalen in exchange for for
about prior to grindrift's attention
this offer was apparently rejected by
U.S officials additionally weyland's
brother has indicated that just days ago
the former U.S service member was being
considered for a one-to-one Swap and
this is these are reports that have
serviced elsewhere that that's uh
originally
before Greiner had ever been arrested
the the U.S had the opportunity to bring
Whalen home in exchange for about and
said no
but then said yes when it was offered
for Griner
so it's pretty clear what actually
happened here
and that they're now lying about it
and why would they choose Greiner over
Whalen or any other American
incarcerated in Russia well that is
clear also in fact a reported Politico
seemed to accidentally acknowledge the
reality here it says this moment ends a
brutal nine months for Grider who has
who was detained at a Moscow airport for
possession of Vape cartridges containing
hash oil she was sentenced in August to
nine years in prison uh so and so forth
along with her Sports Fame the fact that
she
is was a gay black woman the fact that
she was a gay black woman he immense
pressure on the bite Administration to
get her stateside
so those of us who noted immediately
that she got the call because she's gay
and black or we were castigated by the
left we were accused of bringing race
and sexuality into it but as always we
didn't bring it into it we only noted
the fact that they had been brought into
it already
there's a reason why the White House
made a special point of of noting these
demographic details about Greiner
yesterday listen
in recent weeks it became clear that
while Russians were willing to reach an
agreement to secure Britney's release
they continued to treat Paul Whalen
differently given the nature of the
total totally illegitimate charges they
have levied against Paul
unfortunately the choice became to
either bring Brittany home or no one
as the president said this morning he
will he will never stop working to
secure Paul's release and return home
and he will not give up
on a personal note Britney is more than
an athlete more than an Olympic Olympian
she is an important role model and
inspiration to millions of Americans
particularly the lgbtqi plus Americans
and women of color
she should never have been detained by
Russia
and we are I am deeply proud of the work
that the president has done this
Administration has done to get her home
yeah we want to get Paul Whalen home
sure uh yeah yeah fine but hey by the
way Brittany Greiner is gay did you hear
about that
a role model to the lgbtqi community had
to get that I in there for uh intersex
Greiner is an inspiration to those with
genital deformities for some reason so
the claim is that she wasn't chosen
because she's gay and black but gee
isn't it so great that we brought this
woman home who is gay and black
let us all celebrate her homecoming for
these specific reasons yet they had
nothing to do with the decision-making
process that's what we're supposed to
believe CNN also joined in the parade
let's
yeah I think I would be remiss if we did
not mention also the importance this
place for the lgbtq community as we've
been talking about black women this is
big so this is where the lgbtq committee
glad releasing a statement obviously
just I'm summarizing here that they're
happy and it shows the the um struggles
and the danger that members of the LGBT
community face around the world but when
you look at what is happening with the
LGBT community specifically here in the
United States
um what does this say does what does
this bring attention
to that and it shows us hey look we're
all Americans listen uh Brittany Greiner
represents everything in this country uh
she's female she's lgbtq she's black and
she's extraordinary she's excellent
she's overcome she's she's an icon she's
done everything you can do in her Sport
and more and yet she still wasn't safe
she represents everyone he says
she's LGBT black a woman
everyone
though it seems he may have left a few
people out of the every one category we
got LGBT people black people women
who's missing here hmm
no never mind I guess that that is
everyone I guess that's that's the whole
that's all people that exist
we're also told that she's an icon she's
a hero she's a saint among sinners
but why is that exactly she plays
basketball moderately well against a
bunch of women I think she averages I
had to look this up
um there's apparently they keep stats
for for WNBA players which I didn't
realize that and so she averages 17
points a game against a bunch of women
she in a league where nobody when
there's been like three dunks in the
last 30 years
so she does that
and then in her personal life she's a
convicted domestic abuser who had to
enter into a 26-week domestic violence
counseling course a few years ago before
getting arrested for bringing drugs into
a foreign country
icon sure
but in a certain way you know she is an
icon I suppose icons are what are icons
they're symbols and Griner symbolizes
the demographic hierarchy in this
country she's a symbol
of the racial and sexual pecking order
that's what she's a symbol of the
ranking system
and that has never been more clear than
it is now
let's get to the five headlines
it's been a hard year on the economy and
that means that essential practical
gifts will be in high demand this year
well you could give the most essential
gift of all America's best meat and
seafood from good Ranchers with
discounts on orders of five boxes or
more you can save on gifts for the whole
family when you give a box of good
ranchers you're giving them a true
Steakhouse experience with 100 American
USDA prime and upper Choice cuts of beef
Chicken and Seafood other meat delivery
companies and even your local grocery
stores they import lower Quality Meat
from overseas don't give your friends
and families less than America's best
this year not sure what to order well
good ranchers now offers gift cards so
you can let your friends and family
members choose for themselves or give
the gift of a subscription and inflation
proof someone's meat budget go to
goodranchors.com use code wall should
check out get to get 35 off your order
that's goodranchers.com code Walsh for
35 off good ranchers American Meat
delivered
all right this had to be out as before
we move on to the grinder from move on
from the grinder news I wanted to
mention this had to be some kind of
record I think
um competing anyway maybe not right
we're competing for fastest cave to the
woke mob uh Micah Parsons who's a
Cowboys uh place for the Cowboys the
pass rusher he tweeted immediately after
the grinder news was made public he
tweeted in reaction to it
and and has made the point that a lot
many of us were making and are still
making
uh he says wait no we we left a marine
hell no that's what he said okay
so he was upset that we left a marine
that would bring around her but we're
leaving Paul Wayland
uh
and he tweeted this
left was very upset you know even though
this is the same thing many of us were
saying it's like thousands of people on
social media all at once making the same
point but Micah Parsons is uh is a an
athlete and so therefore as far as the
left is concerned he's he belongs to
them you know he they they own him and
also he's black so he's a black athlete
famous guy and so he's not a this is
this is this is not allowed
uh you're not allowed to express a
Viewpoint like this that's that's
slightly outside of
the you know the the accepted talking
points and so the cave began shortly
there after about an hour later he said
my last tweet was no shot at Brittany
Greiner I'm super happy she's back home
as she should be I just have family who
have served and it's crazy to me the
president wouldn't bring him home too
I'm the furthest thing from a trump
supporter but I'm not a fan of Biden
either
hmm
and there was there was nothing in the
original tweet that would indicate that
he's not happy that Bernie Griner is
coming home he just wants this other guy
to come home too he has family that
serves in the military it's very
reasonable position to take
but they weren't happy with that and so
the left kept coming after him and then
and then finally comes the ultimate cave
and uh and this is you know very clearly
not something that was written by him
and so there's a reason why these
apologies always sound the same because
they're written by uh you know PR people
says just spoke to some people that I
respect and Trust I should have been
more educated on the topic and not
tweeted out of emotion for my family and
others who have served for that I
apologize also if what I'm told about
the attempts to bring retired Marine
Paul Whalen home are true then the best
outcome was accomplished I pray Mr
Whalen comes home but I'm extremely
happy for Brittany and her family I am
not too prideful to admit when I've made
a mistake yeah this this is Micah
Parsons talking right his original tweet
was what hell nah what is this multiple
exclamation points emojis and then his
apology is
I pray that Mr Whalen comes home
extremely happy for Britney and her
family I'm not too prideful to admit my
mistakes they don't even try to make it
sound like this is him talking
um
and then the cave is is ultimately
completed now I will say they uh they
the left at least they came up with a
couple clever nicknames for Michael
Parsons I'll give him credit for that
you know they started calling him Maga
Parsons which is yeah that's okay but
then someone came up with
pass Rush Limbaugh
pass Rush Limbaugh is a nickname which
is clever maybe even a little too clever
for a nickname because you have to kind
of think about it for a second anyway
that was enough to get him to back down
doesn't take doesn't take much
um
all right
the other big news of the day happened
uh last night the daily wire has the
report about this the latest release of
the Twitter files Thursday evening
revealed that left us at the highest
levels of the company who have all since
been fired have been forced to resign
targeted one of the most popular
right-wing accounts on the platform with
repeated suspensions despite the fact
that they secretly admitted that she did
not do anything wrong journalist Barry
Weiss released a long Twitter thread in
which she showed how Twitter built
blacklists which by the way they
actually called blacklists
um the prevented disfavor tweets from
trending on the platform and actively
limited the visibility of entire
accounts and even trending topics in
secret without informing users Weiss
noted the different layers of censorship
that existed at Twitter that the highest
level was the site Integrity policy
policy escalation support known as sip
PES sip Pez I guess uh well I said this
secret group included head of uh legal
policy and Trust the global head of
trust and safety subsequent CEOs Jack
Dorsey and uh parag agrawal and others
this is where the biggest most
politically sensitive decisions got made
think High follower account
controversial another employee told us
for these there would be no ticket or
anything and white showed how Libs of
tick tock was placed on a Trends
Blacklist and that a special note was
placed on the account that said action
could not be taken on the account
without consulting the Sip Pez the
account which chayarichik began in
November 2020 and now boasts over 1.4
million followers was subject to six
suspensions 2022 2022 alone each time
write check was blocked for posting for
as long as a week Twitter repeatedly
informed right check that she had been
suspended for violating Twitter's policy
against hateful conduct
however those are the highest levels
secretly admitted that they knew that
lives of tick tock did not violate any
of the site's rules yet they wanted her
suspended anyway
and then um Barry Weiss's a thread goes
on and if there's a lot of documentation
it shows the behind the scenes
correspondence that was going on and it
shows how
um the the head honchos at Twitter they
knew that she wasn't violating any of
the hateful conflict policy they didn't
have any specific tweet they were
looking for something they were looking
for they wanted to permanently suspend
her suspend her but they needed they
needed ammo to do it and so they needed
a specific tweet that directly violates
their hateful conduct policy but she
never gave that to them and so then
instead they settled on just continually
suspending her for a week at a time
um on with the reasoning that she was
indirectly violating the policies what
does indirect violation of policy what
is that exactly what constitutes an
indirect violation of a policy well
obviously anything can constitute that
that's just whatever they decide
is an indirect violation
um and it's not just lives of tick tock
and in the thread they there's uh it
shows how there are a few other examples
were given
um Charlie Kirk was placed on a
blacklist Dan bongino was placed on a
blacklist uh most egregiously of all
actually the most outrageous example are
uh although not surprising
are certain doctors who in the early
days of the covet Panic were placed on
different blacklists and had their
content suppressed
because they were tweeting things that
were not accepted by the left at the
time though have been Vindicated by the
facts
there was one doctor in particular who
tweeted that uh shutting down schools
will be harmful to Children which is a
fact that by the way everyone agrees
with now even on the left
but at the time that he tweeted that
they decided they're going to suppress
his account because of it
and all this is being done
uh without informing anyone it's being
done in secret
and it's being lied about this to me is
this to me is bigger than the hunter
Biden laptop stuff I think they probably
should have led with this
as Elon Musk is going through and and
giving these Scoops to different
reporters
um that he can trust
I think this should have been the first
one this to me is bigger this is this is
this is documentation this is evidence
of widespread systemic bias targeted at
conservatives on political grounds
censoring them secretly while lying
about it
yes we all knew this was happening
we knew that shadow Banning was a thing
but the lefts
mocked us for talking about that said it
was a conspiracy theory and now we have
documented evidence that was happening
and we also know again they were lying
about it they denied it Jack Dorsey when
he was still running things at Twitter
was asked many times whether
conservatives are Shadow banned and he
said no here's just one example of him
apparently lying about it
the president called you out for shadow
Banning what is the truth around that
idea
so I think a lot of the in the the
statements behind the statement the
question behind the question is
um look Shadow Banning is a
very widely defined term there's not one
single definition
um
so
the definition that we found that seems
to resonate with the most people is
um you know not amplifying particular
messages or if someone puts out a tweet
hiding that tweet from everyone without
that person who tweeted it knowing about
it so but the real question behind the
question is are we doing something
according to political ideology or
viewpoints and we are not period we do
not look at content with regards to
political Viewpoint or ideology we look
at Behavior
and we use that behavior as a signal to
to add to relevance we need to
constantly show that we are not adding
our own bias which I fully admit is is
left is is more left-leaning uh and I
think it's important to articulate our
bias into and to and to share people
with share it with people so that people
understand us
but we need to remove all bias from how
we act and our policies and our
enforcement people have these
assumptions that that you're out to get
them or something that and which is why
transparency matters
transparency matters although all this
was being done behind closed doors in
secret and is now being brought to light
uh by Elon Musk now it is true that Jack
Dorsey was was kept out of the loop on a
lot it would seem there's this vast
bureaucracy that was built up
on Twitter and I heard someone on
Twitter put it as as you know Twitter
had its own effectively its own deep
State
um and but the advantage to Twitter
being a private company could be taken
over and just all those people can be
fired which is exactly what Elon Musk
did so Jack Dorsey was kept out of the
loop on something but but at the same
time I think that it's pretty clear that
he knew what he was saying there is not
true
um
especially the idea that the shadow
Banning and all of that was was not
ideologically biased I mean we have now
we have the documented evidence of the
conversations that are going on behind
the scenes and they were targeting
certain accounts and looking for reasons
to get rid of them and if they couldn't
do that then they would just suppress
them
um and we know that now now I will admit
to a certain amount of jealousy
you know uh that's uh that that they
they released the The Blacklist files
for certain accounts like you know
Charlie and Dan and Libs of tick tock I
would love to see my own Blacklist file
that's uh I I would I would love to see
what that looks like
it's I I know for 100 certain obviously
that I've been targeted the same way I
also know as I mentioned before that
they did this you know Barry Weiss's
Twitter thread
she says that they also targeted Twitter
there are certain trends that they would
Target people that they would Shadow ban
and suppress but then also Trends
they're like things they didn't want
trending and uh one of those things I
know for 100 certain was what is a woman
you because when we first announced the
film and we were promoting it and it was
climbing up the trending list made into
the top ten when we first announced the
movie put the trailer out and uh and
then in like 30 seconds it just
disappeared from trending list
completely and never returned uh which
is pretty clear that something was done
behind the scenes saying this is we're
not going to allow this to trend so I'd
like to see my Blacklist file I think
but not just mine you know we need to
see all of this
so it's it's good that Elon Musk is
doing what he's doing
um
he's already done more
to expose
the way things are rigged behind the
scenes
he's doing more in that area than
anyone else in my lifetime certainly any
more than any other than any than any
elected Republican for example has ever
done
um
but we got to go all the way and so we
need to see all of this
release all the files everybody that was
on a blacklist released that release
that everything
put a database out there so that we can
access it and we could see everything
put it all out in the open
there can't be any half measures if
you're going to do this then you got to
go all the way
and we have to see it all
right
here's uh this store is being reported
by uh local CBS News in Las Vegas it
says in energy Department official
this is going to sound like
a little bit of deja vu an energy
Department official is accused of
stealing luggage from Harry Reid
International Airport the eight news now
investigators learned on Thursday a
felony warrant was issued for
Sam Britton a deputy assistant Secretary
of sources said the charges for Grand
Larceny with a value between twelve
hundred and five thousand dollars
Britain is a deputy's assistant
Secretary of official of office of spent
Fuel and waste disposition
Britain faces charges for a similar
incident at the Minneapolis Airport he
was on leave after charges were filed in
connection with that incident
and energy Department spokesman said in
November so
this guy was arrested for stealing a
suitcase
and the original theft was in was I
didn't want to know Minneapolis
and now he's arrested again for doing it
again now it's not clear when when like
did this theft happen
in the last week and after he was
already arrested for the first one or
did this happen earlier so the timeline
isn't exactly clear but what we do know
is that he's stolen at least two
suitcases now
that on top of everything else we know
about him about him being a dog
fetishist BDSM Enthusiast gives classes
on um on spanking and you know it goes
against spanking 101 classes at College
colleges and all that so all that stuff
we know and now he's also a Serial
luggage thief on top of it
and by the way just to be clear again
I see some people accusing him of being
a kleptomaniac like he has some sort of
compulsion to steal that's not what this
is he is being driven by compulsion but
it's not a compulsion to steal it's
pretty clear what he's doing here he's
stealing luggage from women because he's
a cross-dressing fetishist and uh he has
a thing for stealing women's clothes and
wearing them which is why when the first
item of was taken when the first when
the first piece of luggage was taken
they never did recover any of the
clothes I wonder why that is
so that's what's going on here it's it's
it's even creepier a lot creepier than
simply being a kleptomaniac
this is a uh a pervert who is being
driven by his perversions and has no
control over them apparently
I mean to steal luggage from an airport
in the first place when the whole when
when you know there are
10 cameras watching you at any given
moment
that's already insane but to do it again
after you've already been arrested the
first time uh this just shows this is
someone who has no control over their
actions a pervert who is driven by those
perversions
and yet was
a high-ranking official with a high
security clearance
now this is a point I want to I might
flesh out a little bit more next week
um because it's important point but I do
want to mention one other point one
other thing about this
which is that
I think the Sam Britain case
I mean it shows a lot
um it it shows why it's
suicidally stupid to hire people based
on um you know diversity equity and
inclusion
for that to be the litmus test
so it obviously demonstrates that I
think it also demonstrates why we need
to bring back bullying in this country
we need a lot more bullying not less
I think we've made a massive mistake
by um our our anti-bullying efforts have
been misguided I think we've made a
mistake
by raising our kids and and telling them
that the worst thing you can ever do
that's the worst thing bullying is the
worst thing
um you know you should never mock or
belittle something that's weird
something that's strange
and and even the freakiest weirdos among
you don't don't make fun of them don't
point and laugh don't mock them
right treat them like it's normal
even the weirdest
strangest things treat it like normal
because if you don't then you're
bullying and that's the worst thing in
the world
and then what happens you end up with
people like Sam Britton
who feel totally empowered to act out
their weirdest most disgusting
compulsions in public
they have at a point now they have no
control over it
because they've been empowered this way
Sam Britton is someone who would have
benefited from a lot of bullying when he
was younger and probably if you listen
to his story he'll tell you I was
bullied a lot no it's pretty clear that
he wasn't
he needed to be
he needed people to point at him and say
the way you're acting right now this is
this is freaking weird man stop it
you're acting like a freak stop all this
he needed to feel that that shame and
that he needed to establish like well
why is everyone's pointing and laughing
at me I'm I'm ashamed like there's
something wrong with me he needed to
feel that and then it needed to be told
not that oh no everything's fine with
you no yeah there is something wrong
with you
you know we need to get you some therapy
some counseling
you get you got a thing for wearing dog
masks and and leather in public like
that's not that's that's not that is
strange
that is something that we should Mock
and laugh at
that that is that's an appropriate
natural reaction right
mockery laughter
all of that that's an appropriate
natural reaction to bizarre perverted
things
and we should that's the reaction we
should have
but we like beat that reaction out of
people
and insist that they treat everything
like it's normal even if it's not and
then you end up with Sam Britain
all right John Kerry whose official
title is U.S Special presidential Envoy
for the climate
was asked this week about the
possibility of the U.S paying climate
reparations whatever those are uh and
not just on its own behalf but on behalf
of other countries too footing their
bill to uh pay money to heal the climate
to appease the nature of gods and here's
what he said
depending on the lesson damage fund
though I mean is there going to have to
be U.S taxpayer money that helps the
United States presumably the United
States is going to have to be one of the
Nations that contributes great if there
were some
it's uh I mean the United States of
America proudly is the largest
humanitarian
donor in the world the American people
already do an enormous amount around the
world
hmm
uh so we should we should be doing some
of that he says we should be paying we
should be paying for other countries we
all need to be paying climate
reparations and again it's not exactly
clear what that is or how that would so
you pay money and then it's it it
changes the weather
not sure I see the connection there but
we should be doing it on behalf of other
countries too
and then I always love when these people
say well the American people they're
already they're already contributing so
much and doing so much
yeah we are because this is our money
but we you make it sound like it's our
choice which it isn't right you're
making it sound like this is our you
know all the foreign aid that we give
out all the money that we give to uh
foreign governments
no taxation you know there's no taxation
there's no representation in this
taxation where we're giving money to
foreign governments have no idea how
they're going to spend it uh have no
control over how it's been we don't
benefit American families don't benefit
from that money because we're giving it
to foreign governments and yeah we're
doing all of that but it's not our
choice this is this is all this is all
happening against our will
but
you know we've long since normalized
this idea and a lot of people have grown
accustomed to this idea of the of the
United States government handing out
checks to foreign governments
billions and billions and billions of
dollars to dozens and dozens of foreign
governments every single year
with no accountability whatsoever
all right what else do we have here
um
I think we got to skip right ahead to
this because I don't want to want to
make sure we don't we don't to lose our
opportunity to talk about it
uh okay here it is from The Washington
Post
Lisa white knack
loved sharks as a kid she spent rainy
days leafing through a guide to sharks
and Readers Digest every summer she
would watch shark week which is
discovery's annual TV event that spy
light that spotlights the ocean Predator
with seven days of dedicated programming
but when the scientists appeared on her
TV screen she rarely saw any women she
could look up to
why would I know I could do that white
Knack said I don't come from a family of
scientists I didn't see very many people
that look like me on television
white Knack now a biology professor at
Allegheny College in Pennsylvania found
her way into shark research anyway when
the pandemic lockdowns began in 2020 she
saw an opportunity to study the sources
of her old misconceptions was Shark Week
feeding audiences the wrong messages
about sharks and who studies them
white Knack led a team of researchers to
examine hundreds of Shark Week episodes
that aired between 1988 and 2020.
this is the kind of research that's
being done this is the kind of this is
the kind of scientific research that's
being funded these days
um if you're wondering what the what the
scientists are are working on
you know like why why haven't we gotten
back to the Moon yet why don't we have a
care for cancer yet well they're the
scientists are working on this sort of
thing
uh looking into the the diversity in
Shark Week programming in a study
published last month by the public
library of science their research claims
that discoveries programming emphasized
negative messages about sharks lacked
useful messaging about shark
conservation and
and overwhelmingly featured white men as
experts including several men with the
same name the programming featured more
white experts and commentators named
Mike than women so they're even looking
at there are not just too many white men
who are studying sharks but there are
too many white men named Mike can we at
least get some other names in there
um anyway it goes on
let's see
David schiffman is a conservationist at
Arizona State University was a co-author
on the study when there are hundreds of
people of color interested who work in
this field and when my field is more
than half women maybe it's not an
accident anymore that they're only
featuring white men
Discovery did not respond to requests
for comment on the study's findings
and by the way that's not because
Discovery is just going to laugh this
off as they should okay and it's not
because they're laughing it off and
saying what their response should be you
know the response should be like are you
kidding me I don't who cares
but no they're just they're they're
talking to their PR people and
eventually they're going to issue some
uh you know mayor culpa come to Jesus
great grand apology if they haven't
already I haven't even looked up this
this story is a few days old so they may
have already done this
um
outlining what all the steps they're
going to take to make sure there's more
diversity in Shark Week programs that's
what's going to happen
the company told NBC Boston that it
wouldn't comment on a study that has yet
to pass any scientific approvals after
preliminary version was presented in
2021. it has since undergone a
scientific review
okay
well we could continue reading that if
you want but I think we probably don't
need to
we are and we are so far beyond the
bounds of parity at this point
that I did I read through the entire
thing because I was honest to God
expecting that they would also say that
the focus on great white sharks in
particular is racist or that there's
some kind of encoded message there that
we're always taught oh great white I was
really expecting that like unironically
I was expecting that would be in there
and it wasn't
but uh nearly as absurd as that
and remember it's not just that there's
not enough diversity among people who
are talking about sharks
uh but also that the that it is painting
a negative message about sharks
sharks are actually quite friendly
like nothing to worry about if you're
swimming in the ocean and you see that
the dorsal fin go by nothing to worry
about don't uh don't be don't be don't
make assumptions don't make a biased
stereotypical assumptions just based on
the fact that there is this prehistoric
death machine swimming right next to you
one thing for sure next year's Shark
Week okay after this next year Shark
Week you've never seen diversity like
what they're gonna do and every single
Stark expert I guarantee you there will
not be one white male shark expert
allowed in next next year is a Shark
Week uh certainly none named Mike you're
gonna see there's gonna be black shark
ax but they're gonna find women there's
there's they're gonna throw in some
trans shark experts
and if there aren't any trans shark
experts they'll just bring in some trans
people in general whether they know
anything about sharks or not maybe
they'll bring in a trans person who's
seen the movie Jaws and uh get there get
their comment on it
you've never seen diversity like what
we're going to see next next year all
right let's get to the comment section
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it was a show before Christmas and
through the studio
no other host was stirring not even
Shapiro
all the merch was set on the shelves
with care
in hopes that Sweet Daddy soon would be
there
the sweet babies were nestled all snug
in their beds
while visions of walruses danced in
their heads
then over on Twitter there arose such a
clatter
I was trending on the timeline for some
erroneous matter
but I ignored it like every other time
shrugging off the satanic unhinged blue
hair slime
then my merch making elves created a
collectible new batch adding to my
coveted program the sweet Santa Baby
patch
they'll sell out for my store so don't
wait don't stop just head on over to
dailywire.com shop
Black Rifle coffee company is helping
you knock out your holiday shopping with
a ton of awesome new products this year
shop the best Brewing gear thermoses
mugs and apparel designed for folks who
love country and coffee black rival
source is the most exotic roast from
around the globe all coffee is roasted
here in the US by veteran-led teams of
coffee experts you can stuff your
Christmas stockings with the latest
roast from America's coffee for 10 off
with my code Walsh better yet sign your
Secret Santa up for a coffee Club
subscription imagine the joy of a
pre-scheduled coffee delivery your
favorite roast when you need the most
it's the gift that keeps on giving Black
Rifle coffee company is veteran founded
and operated they take pride in serving
coffee and culture to people who love
America every purchase you make with
Black Rifle helps support veteran and
first responder causes so go to Black
riflecoffee.com use promo code Walsh for
10 off coffee Coffee Gear apparel or
when you sign up for a new coffee Club
subscription that's black
riflecoffee.com with promo code walls
for 10 off Black Rifle coffee supporting
veterans and America's coffee
tie my shoe says I'm convinced Dylan is
a top-tier Troll he's playing the long
game and then reg pither agrees Dylan
Mulvaney is clearly playing a character
role to the hilt like Sasha Baron
Cohen's Borat or Bruno and he's laughing
at everyone who is embracing his clearly
ridiculous portrayal of girlhood while
also raking in the dollars some kind of
Twisted genius I've seen this a lot of
other comments like this and and this to
me seems like a cope this is just cope
this is uh I heard there was similar
theories were bandied about uh about
that the Canadian teacher with the
ridiculous prosthetic breasts and there
were there were people theorizing that
maybe this is a troll maybe maybe this
is actually someone who's conservative
is trying to make a point about you know
the the excesses of gender ideology so
it seems to be the theory here as well
again the theory really is that so if
this is true
then Dylan Mulvaney not only a comedic
genius but uh this is that this would
actually be quite heroic because if this
is a troll and he's doing all of this to
mock gender ideology he's getting all of
these sponsorships and everything when
eventually he says hey I see I got you
this is all a troll when he says that uh
he's going to be
D platform from everything he's just
pissed off like every corporation that's
sponsoring him right now and he's gonna
be Public Enemy Number One
so this is kind of like a Kamikaze
mission to expose the absurdity of
gender ideology that's I suppose your
theory and uh I think that's a cope I
don't think that's the case at all I
think you want that to be true because
you look at Dylan Mulvaney and you say
to yourself like there's no way this
this can be sincere I mean this is what
we're actually supposed to take this
seriously there's no way this has got to
be a joke
you're just because you're a normal
person
and
you you you don't want to deal with how
insane the culture has gotten and so you
see something like this and you think
it's got to be a joke but it's not just
like that the Washington Post article I
just read about the you know the lack of
diversity in Shark Week
you might hear that and say well that's
got to be a joke it's not a joke
I mean it is a joke in a certain sense
but it's not an intentional joke let's
put it that way
uh now uh on the other hand if what
you're saying is Well Dylan Mulvaney
he's not really trans
well sure in a certain sense you're
right he's not really trans because
nobody really is like he's not actually
a woman he's claiming to be a woman he's
not really that so we know that
um but is this intended by him to be
some kind of troll I think no I think
it's entirely sincere
all right
duel says you're jealous Matt angry
bitter and jealous
so I'm trying to think who I talked
about in yesterday's show that I would
be jealous of
sometimes you see these comments and
they're outside they have no context for
them because they're reacting to a
certain part of the show but they don't
tell me what part it is so who am I
angry bitter and jealous who am I
jealous of my you saying I'm jealous of
Brittany Greiner so we started the show
with yesterday
and you know what I kind of am
because she's you know she's made
millions of dollars
with her mediocre basketball Talent uh
and I'm I'm somewhat jealous of that
I'm probably as good at basketball as
she is and yet she's making millions of
dollars off of it so yeah in a way I
kind of I guess I am
Jack says ADHD uh isn't just
inattentiveness it's a deficiency of
certain receptors in the brain to
process dopamine most people with ADHD
only get that high from dopamine when
engaging in novel or exciting things and
can quickly lose it when those things
get boring hence the struggle with
homework but not video games it also
presents as extreme hyper fixations and
hobbies when they find something that
gives them that hit of dopamine
medication for ADHD increases dopamine
levels in the brain to Baseline levels
so they can regulate mood and focus
better it's very easy to mistake
especially in children with just being
hyper or bored it's wildly over
diagnosed today but it is a real thing
being an adult with severe ADHD
sometimes verges into being debilitating
especially when working with from home
but the best medicine isn't microdosing
meth it's going outside exercising
regularly and balancing your diet okay
so at the very end there I can
I I agree with you that the best
medicine for some the best medicine for
a quote condition like this
um is not
you know psychotropic drugs it's
lifestyle changes and all that so that
that I can agree with you but
connecting ADHD to dopamine and
receptors in the brain and all of that I
mean you're stating this like it's a
fact
but when I look into it what I find are
you know you know reports about studies
that indicate a potential link maybe
between ADHD and dopamine but they don't
even know what exactly the link is
so that's that's so you you are you are
making a much stronger case than what
the evidence actually allows it's
actually quite similar to this serotonin
theory of depression
which of course has since been revealed
to be you know essentially a myth
but that was built from there were a few
studies done that indicated maybe
there's a connection possibly maybe and
the next thing you know according to
doctors and pharmaceutical companies
it's a 100 fact
and that's just that's not how it works
that's not how science works
and by the way if ADHD ADHD and this is
the same point I always made about
depressions the same point I make about
a lot of these supposed mental illnesses
if it is something that is entirely
based in brain chemistry if it's
something that can be located in the
brain
then why don't they diagnose it
with brain scans
why not
that's not how they diagnose it
okay they don't diagnose ADHD by looking
at the child's brain they don't do that
at all what they ask you are questions
about his behavior
that's all they ask and then they make
the diagnosis based on that
are they going to eat you know do they
do they do the the behavior survey and
then they say well we think your child
this Joe might have a ADHD let's do some
brain scans and take a look
and then and then when they look at the
brain scan and say well you know it
looks it looks like it's not actually
ADHD no they don't do that
uh and that's because it's not based in
brain chemistry it's based in you know
this is this is entirely in an invention
based on uh behavior that we find
Troublesome or
uh inconvenient
so this is a diagnosis of behavior it's
not a diagnosis of the brain
you know we recently launched a brand
new biblical series by Dr Jordan B
Peterson this series is called Exodus
and in it Jordan Peterson sits down with
other Scholars to read the book of
Exodus and to discuss what it means and
why it remains significant thousands of
years after it was written Scholars at
the table include Dennis Prager uh
Jonathan Pago and many more the first
few episodes are available to stream
right now and there are more new
episodes coming soon trust me you don't
want to see uh to miss this check out
the trailer
in the beginning God created the heavens
and the Earth
[Music]
turns out that a book is more durable
than than Stone it's more durable than a
castle it's more durable than an Empire
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and God is ethic-centered not
ethnic-centered well do you want the
Pharaoh on your side or do you want God
on your side that's kind of the question
there's a profound sense here that what
is going on with the Israelites is the
contrast to Pharaoh right like under no
terms where you go and the Israel's had
to say we will go under any terms and
we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest ethical Spirit to
which we're beholden is presented
precisely as that spirit that allies
itself with the cause of Freedom against
tyranny yes exactly I want villains to
get punished but do you want the
villains to learn before they have to
pay the ultimate price that's such a
Christian question
well you got to be a member to watch the
head of dailywire.com Walsh to become a
member and watch Exodus today now let's
get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
we spent a lot of time focusing on the
fact that Hollywood constantly churns
out woke propaganda pieces disguised as
Cinema and that's of course true
and a large part of the reason why
audiences are losing interest in movies
this past Thanksgiving box office tally
a time when theaters typically rake in
massive amounts of money saw the weakest
performance in over 25 years this in
spite of the fact that there or maybe
because of the fact there were multiple
sequels to Blockbuster franchise films
showing uh there was a new Steven
Spielberg movie there was a Disney
cartoon about a gay teenage boy and a
disabled dog
you know all these things were at
theater and uh nobody went like I said
wokeness is certainly part of the
problem here but not the whole problem
because the other issue is that so many
movies are boring and dull and simply
not anything to get excited about
and it seems that the people involved in
making these cinematic versions of bland
stale graham crackers are aware at some
level of how boring and uninteresting it
all is and that's why they have to go to
increasingly desperate lengths to
pretend that their films are somehow
revolutionary and provocative even as
they serve up the same under seasoned
dish that we've had a million times
before
and I think that's part of what was
happening this week when Jennifer
Lawrence now uh somewhat infamously sat
down for an interview with variety and
ended up claiming a title for herself
that
people older than 10 years old might
find surprising as it doesn't quite gel
with our memories
Lawrence declared that she is the first
actress to have ever starred in a
Hollywood action film now Jennifer
Lawrence is 32 okay she's not in her 70s
or 80s which she would have to be in
order for that claim to have any chance
of legitimacy but uh let's watch the
clip first
I remember when I was doing Hunger Games
nobody had ever put a woman in the lead
of an action movie because it wouldn't
work we were told girls and boys can
both identify with a male lead but boys
cannot identify with a female lead oh
absolutely and it just makes me so happy
every single time I see a movie come out
that just blows through every single one
of those beliefs and proves
that it is just a lie to keep certain
people out of the movies to keep certain
people in the same positions that
they've always been in and it's just
amazing to watch it happen and watch you
at the helm
yes the Hunger Games released in 2012
was the that was the the first action
film with a female lead Lawrence then
noted that it was also a great honor to
co-star in the Silver Linings Playbook
so that she could get a front row seat
to Robert De Niro's first film role and
she's especially humbled to realize that
when she played Mystique in X-Men first
Class she was starring in the first
superhero movie ever made truly an
historic career in her own mind if not
in reality because in reality of course
Sigourney Weaver exists Linda Hamilton
exists Angelina Jolie exists there have
been many female action Stars over the
decades going back to Carrie Fisher in
Star Wars even before her there were
others
um Jennifer Lawrence is not the first to
do anything
nor the best
she didn't even come up with like a new
way of doing something she just followed
a script that had long since been
written trying to pretend that she's
breaking glass ceilings that have been
laying in shards on the ground for
decades
glass ceilings that in this case we
should note never mattered much to begin
with
okay the fact that there are more men
starring in action films than women who
cares it makes sense that most action
stars are men as men typically make more
compelling and believable action Stars
typically okay it's a lot harder to make
a female action here into anything but a
silly cartoon Sigourney Weaver pulled it
off which is why her performance is
still remembered by everyone except
Jennifer Lawrence apparently and yet
more often it ends up being a kind of
goofy girl power routine
men can can also see a man it's easier
for a male actor to elevate goofy action
plots and lend them a certain gravitas
Batman is an absolutely ridiculous
concept okay it is it's just absurd you
gotta guide dresses up in a rubber
costume as a bat running around it's
it's ridiculous and yet every man in the
role except maybe George Clooney has
pulled it off with varying degrees of
success meanwhile there's never been a
bat girl that was anything but cringe on
steroids
because men are more natural for these
roles and and generally generally
speaking they're just better at them
um all that to say
there was never a problem of Too Many
Men acting in action films there were
there were more men than women acting in
them um up until recently now because
now you can't have a you know a white
male lead for anything
but that's not a problem it wasn't a
problem
any more than there was ever a problem
of of there being too many men who are
roofers you know you notice that the
feminists are always very selective
about the professions where they demand
representation
I think I've seen maybe one female in my
life riding on the back of a trash truck
through the neighborhood
somehow though there's no National
discourse about the representation
problem in the waste disposal industry
so it's okay
for gender disparities to exist in
certain contexts for feminists
but in reality it's it yeah it is it's
okay in general it's a gender
disparities are natural
because men and women are different
and they gravitate towards different
things and they have and they have
aptitudes in different things in
different areas
uh women are better in certain areas
generally men are better in certain
areas generally that's just that's just
that that's that's the nature of uh
that's human nature
it's the attempts to artificially even
everything out
that tends to always cause more problems
than it solves
this is somewhat immaterial because the
point here is that Jennifer Lawrence
came along after females had already
made their entrance into the action film
genre she's trying to recycle
Progressive victories from a generation
before her and we've seen this similar
charade with uh we see this all the time
with the left but we've seen it in
Hollywood we've seen with other movies
such as when Black Panther was
celebrated as some kind of breakthrough
because it was a film with a mostly
Black cast even though such films have
been made by Hollywood for years for
decades there have been black
superheroes before as well we had them
in the 90s
so black panther didn't Pioneer anything
Ross douthit made this point in his book
decadent society which he quoted in
response to Jennifer Lawrence's flub and
reading from the passage is what he says
the reality of recurrence may be
slightly harder for progressives to
acknowledge than conservatives because
progressivism is more invested in its
supposed position at the Vanguard of
cultural change pressing boldly on to
New Frontiers this makes it difficult
for the left to recognize the
generational recycling of its Ambitions
and anxieties the fact that many
Progressive breakthroughs are just the
cultural cycling the culture cycling
back to something that we did not that
long ago up to and including Kick-Ass
female action heroes such as Wonder
Woman who followed a path Blaze by
Sigourney Weaver's Ripley in the alien
movies or the robot wrangling Sarah
Connor and the Terminator movies or even
the Blaster wielding Princess Leia in
the Star Wars 40 years before that or
the African-American Heroes and Black
Panther in truth black stars were
arguably more important in the years of
Eddie Murphy and Richard Pryor in The
Cosby Show and The Young Denzel
Washington then in our officially
representation obsessed age
now his book decadent Society is about
as you may have guessed decadence we are
a decadent Society in the sense that we
as doubt that has it are locked in this
kind of cultural stalemate Treading
Water adrift board recycling the same
ideas and themes
now I don't agree with all of his thesis
but when it comes to our artistic output
there is no question about it
a decadent Society
with decadent celebrities clamoring to
be cultural revolutionaries
in a culture that they have already won
they already own it
and that ultimately is why Jennifer
Lawrence is today canceled
and I'll do it for the show today talk
to you on Monday Godspeed
[Music]
the executive producer of the Matt wall
show is Sean Hampton our associate
producer is McKenna Waters the show is
directed by Mark Jones and Trey Miller
our production manager is Pavel vadoski
second assistant director Austin
Michaelis the show is edited by Jeff
Tomlin Our lead audio engineer is Mike
cormina our hair and makeup artist is
Cherokee heart our wardrobe stylist our
Kristen galaraga and Elizabeth Fox
director production is Mathis Glover
director of Technology Mark Herman our
camera studio and equipment manager is
Patrick Kennedy our lighting directors
Keith Duggan host production manager
Matt Kemp episode art is created by
Morgan Pierce our executive in charge of
production is David wermis executive
producer Jeremy Borg the Matt Walsh show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
Republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the Andrew klavan show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew klavan
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the Republic with me Andrew Clavin
[Music]